Marvel Studios has announced what's on
their plate through 2021 giving us
plenty to speculate about when it comes
to just what phase four will entail from
plot details to casting rumors
surprising character connections he is
everything we've heard so far on the
heels of a tragic death in Avengers
endgame Scarlett Johansson's keraton
Natasha Romanov will be kicking off
phase four of the MCU with her long
anticipated black widow movie this film
will be set here in the MCU timeline
between Captain America Civil War and
Avengers infinity war back when the
Tasha was still alive and kicking but in
the film Natasha is Russian spy pass
seems to be catching up with her as she
contends with fellow Red Room graduates
Yelena Bulova played by Florence Pugh
Rachel Weisz will also be part of the
film but all we know about her character
so far is that she's named Melina
however fans have speculated that she
could be Melina Vostok off who's known
as Iron Maiden in the comics David
Harbor is also on board as Alexey Shah
skirt off otherwise known as the Red
Guardian a sort of Russian version of
Captain America the film's main villain
will be the copycats taskmaster but
there's no word yet on who will be
behind the characters skull mask
we'll see how Natasha fares against him
on May 1st
2020 the stage was star-studded at 2019
San Diego comic-con with a brilliant and
sample cast of the Eternals set to
release November 6 2020 this film will
follow a group of ancient godlike aliens
many of whom have ties to Greek
mythology Angelina Jolie will play thena
whose character is a reference to the
Olympian goddess Athena Richard Madden
of Game of Thrones famous playing Icarus
one of the mightiest Eternals names for
the Greek myth of the boy who flew too
close to the Sun the eternal Fastow's
played by Bryan Tyree Henry it's a
pseudo have Festus due to his weapons
mething skills while sprite played by
Lea McHugh is a young low-key like
trickster Kumail Nanjiani will play
Kingo an eternal who's been living in
Japan for millennia following the way of
the samurai and Don Lee will be playing
Gilgamesh and although the characters of
a jack and the death
Hermes inspired Macari are both male in
the comics they'll be portrayed on
screen by Salma Hayek and deaf actress
Lauren red laughs then during the 2019
d23 Expo in
Anaheim a few more exciting names were
added to the already impressive Eternals
cast Jemma Chan who played the ill-fated
Minerva in Captain Marvel will be
rejoining the MCU in the Eternals a
Circe in the comics Circe lives among
humans in New York throwing lavish
parties where she entertains her guests
by passing her superpowers off as magic
tricks also joining the cast of Barry
kyun as the vicious ex-kgb agent Dueck
and the game of thrones actor ket's
Harrington as a non eternal superhero
Dayne Whitman also known as Black Knight
Harrington's role will reunites him with
his Game of Thrones brother Richard
Madden and may seem like familiar
territory for viewers since Black Knight
is also the recipient of a weighty
family legacy and the thematically
significant sword Canadian actor C mu
Leo will be portraying the hero Chang
Chi in shang-chi and the legend of the
ten ranks and Kevin Feige has promised
that he will soon be a household name
everywhere Leo is probably best known
for his role in the sitcom Kim's
convenience but his action experience
comes from his role in the TV series
taken and to stunt work on the sets of
designated survivor and heroes reborn
Lee you had actually tweeted about his
interest on the role back in December of
2018
using the shang-chi hashtag the actor
wrote okay Marvel are we gonna talk or
what
apparently Marvel and the you did talk
and he thanked the studio on Twitter for
getting back to him when his role was
officially announced starring alongside
Leo in shang-chi and the legends of the
ten rings will be Aquafina of crazy rich
Asians fame will also finally meet the
real Mandarin as opposed to the fake
version played by Ben Kingsley in Iron
Man 3 the Mandarin is the leader of the
ten rings terrorists organization and
will be played by a ward winning actor
Tony Lee young we'll see what kind of
villain the real Mandarin is on February
12 2021 rather than focusing solely on
big blockbuster films the MCU is
expanding into the world of television
for phase four the next few years we'll
see a group of new Marvel shows
releasing on the streaming platform
Disney Plus which was all tied directly
into the established world of the MCU
releasing in the summer of 2021 the
animated series what if promises to
being especially intriguing look at the
world of Marvel based on the comic
series of the same name
what if we'll explore
alternate versions of the events in the
MCU the show's voice cast boasts a
staggering number of MCU movie stars
from Michael B Jordan to Michael Rooker
the series first episode will focus on
what would have happened if Hayley
Atwell character Peggy Carter took the
Super Soldier Serum instead of Steve
Rogers in Captain America the First
Avenger will watch these alternate
timelines and fold through the eyes of
the watcher voiced by West world's
Jeffrey Wright Steve Rogers two best
friends Bucky Barnes and Sam Wilson will
team up against Captain America Civil
War villain Zemo in the Falcon and the
Winter Soldier coming to Disney Plus in
the fall of 2020 the series will star
Anthony Mackie and Sebastian Stan as the
Falcon and the Winter Soldier and will
feature the return of Daniel Bruhl ASIMO
Emily VanCamp as Sharon Carter and Wyatt
Russell as new character John Walker but
wait isn't some supposed to be Captain
America now at the end of Avengers end
game and age Steve Rogers handed his red
white and blue shield over to Sam as
Bucky looked on approvingly
never fear in an interview with MTV News
Mackey promised that the new Captain
America will make his debut at some
point during the Falcon and the Winter
Soldier he's already been fitted for his
new star-spangled suit and according to
Mackey it looks really good
where did Loki go when he snatched up
the tesseract and disappeared from 2012
during Avengers end games time heist
apparently will get the chance to find
out in the upcoming Disney Plus Series
Loki Tom Hiddleston will be reprising
his role as a god of mischief and has
been confirmed that the series picks up
right after Loki winked out of existence
the actor told San Diego comic-con at
the Loki series is one of the most
exciting creative opportunities he's
ever encountered saying that he couldn't
wait to get started in addition to a new
world
Loki may also take us to a whole new
time period a preview image for the
series shows sauce younger brother in
front of a promotional sign for the film
jaws which was released in 1975 without
the time stone we have no idea how
Loki's managing is time hopping but
we'll have to wait until the show
releases in the spring of 2021 to find
out
Marvel has been pretty mysterious when
it comes to wonder vision the third of
its new Disney Plus shows especially
when it comes to how the series fits
into the current MCU timeline vision
played by Paul Bettany
was killed by Thanos at the N
of Avengers infinity war so how is he
supposed to star alongside his
girlfriend wander in a show that takes
place after the events of Avengers ends
game in the words of Elizabeth Olsen who
plays Wonder maksimov it's gonna get
weird also unclear is how Monica Rambeau
will factor into the storyline of one
division the young Monica first charmed
audiences with her mischief in Captain
Marvel and one division will feature the
character all grown up the adult Monica
will be played by Tiana Paris who might
even get in on the superhero action
herself she'll be joined by kat dennings
reprising her role as Darcy Lewis from
the first two Thor movies Randal
Parker's Jimmy woo from ant-man and the
wasp and newcomer Kathryn Hahn as Wonder
and visions nosy neighbor
we'll find out so they all come together
but one division arrives on Disney Plus
in the spring of 2021 phonetics
Cumberbatch is Doctor Strange is getting
his own sequel and phase 4 ominously
titled Doctor Strange in the multiverse
of madness Elizabeth Olsen's Wanda
Maximoff will be co-starring in the film
which will slide directly into the
events of one division and we wouldn't
be surprised if multiverse of madness
also crossed over with the alternate
universes of Marvel's animated what-if
series the title for the strange sequel
leads us to suspect that some
Lovecraftian adventures are in store for
the sorcerer supreme and director scott
derrickson seem to confirm our
suspicions speaking to the audience at
San Diego Comic Con about what drew him
to the doctor strange comics and what
his plans were for the film sequel
derrickson said they dipped into the
Gothic and the horror and the horrific
and we're going to make the first scary
MCU film we'll discover the mysteries of
the multiverse when Doctor Strange in
the multiverse of madness is unveiled on
May 7th 2021
it's been a rocky relationship but after
a brief trial separation
sodium Marvel have officially gotten
back together for one more film
spider-man 3 will release on July 16th
of 2021 making it a belated addition to
the MCU space for
no casting has been confirmed yet but
it's safe to assume that in addition to
Tom Holland will also be seeing the
return of Jacob battle or nurse Ned and
zendaya as MJ as well as Marisa Tomei as
Aunt May and Jon Favreau was happy Hogan
and given the cliffhangers at the end of
spider-man far from home would be
surprised if JK Simmons does
make an appearance as Joe Jana Jameson
as well like the first two films the MCU
spider-man 3 will be held by director
John watts no plot details have been
released for the third spider-man outing
yet including whether or not it will
crossover with venom or any other parts
of Sony's own spider-verse however since
the MCU only has Peter Parker confirmed
for one more movie we're prepared for
spider-man 3 to pave the way for Spidey
to exit the Marvel Cinematic Universe
for good Sony has been pretty eager to
get Detroit spider-man villains a
sinister six on screen for a long time
and has in fact already introduced
several of the group's members such as
the vulture and spider-man homecoming a
Mysterio in spider-man far from home
spider-man 3 would be an excellent
opportunity to round out the lineup by
bringing in another member of the group
and the most likely candidate to battle
Spidey in a third Marvel now saying is
Kraven the hunter before it officially
been tapped to direct spider-man 3
John Watts mentioned that if the villain
of the third movie was up to him it
would be Kraven what's more far from
home scribes Chris McKenna and Eric
summers have mentioned Kraven as the
next villain they'd like to see Spidey
fight additionally Sony is already
working on developing a Kraven solo film
which means the hunter is already on his
way to the big screen we'll just have to
wait to find out whether he makes a stop
in the MCU first set to release in the
fall of 2021 the series logo for Hawkeye
is almost an exact replica of the one
used for the much-loved comic run by
Matt Fraction
and David Archer fraction and archers
stylish series which focus on Clint
Barton's everyday non superhero life
place particular emphasis on the archers
various relationships especially between
Barton and his protege Kate Bishop a
master strategist and fighter with
deadly aim the Kate Bishop of the comics
is also the leader of the young Avengers
but is otherwise a down-to-earth human
like Barton Bishop is confirmed to have
a spot in the Hawkeye series and will
presumably take over the Hawkeye man
tour from Clint at some points like she
does in the comics we can't wait to see
the dynamic between Jeremy Renner's
laid-back Hawkeye as he meant us a
sharply witty Kate after the massive
success of Thor Ragnarok directed cycle
ytt is returning to helm the fourth
installment in the Thor series Thor love
and thunder but when the film rumbles
into theaters on November 5th 2021 Hills
will be bringing a new
Thunder with it while chris hemsworth
will be returning a saw ytt announced
that Natalie Portman's Jane Foster will
take on me or Nia in love and thunder to
become Mighty Thor in the comics Jane
became the Thorburn Thor was no longer
worthy of Mjolnir while Thor renamed
himself Odinson and went off to travel
the universe Tessa Thompson will also
return as Valkyrie to Creed the king of
newest guard at the end of endgame
Thompson already has her own ideas about
what Valkyries first order of business
will be in love and thunder telling the
audience of San Diego comic-con quote
she needs to find her Queen many will
remember wesley snipes iconic
performance at the sharp fangs sharp
witted title character in the original
blade trilogy of films now Oscar winning
actor Maher Sheela Ali will be stepping
into the role of the half vampiric
vampire hunter for a new Marvel solo
film calling the MC use new blade one of
our times greatest working actors Kevin
Feige revealed that Ali was already a
huge fan of the Marvel Cinematic
Universe as well as the character of
blade himself not long before he was
cast in the role
Feige went on to say he's gonna destroy
the part I mean he's just it's a dream
it's the kind of dream casting that you
almost don't dare to dream that you
could actually do it the mysterious
twitter user who correctly predicted a
number of key plot points and avengers
endgame months before the movie came out
is back with a possible phase 4 scoop
according to that accounts which goes by
the handle
Roger Waddell Marvel Studios are a big
fan of David Morrissey and are
considering multiple roles for him for
phase 4 Morrissey gains fame among comic
book fans when he embodied one of The
Walking Dead's biggest and baddest
villains the governor he's been proving
his versatility ever since playing more
than just megalomaniacs but we wouldn't
mind if he brought another bad guy to
life
we could see Morrissey taking on the
role of spider-man villain Norman Osborn
or iconic Fantastic Four antagonist
Doctor Doom
on the other hand just because Morrissey
has paid villains on the past doesn't
mean he can't play a good guy now after
all Marvel still has plenty of heroic
roles left to fill
whether he comes aboard as a hero or a
villain we're sure Morrissey will make a
fantastic addition to the MCU just when
we thought we knew everything to expect
in phase 4 of the MCU Marvel threw us
for a loop by announcing a trio of
additional new MCU shows at the 2019 d23
Expo MS marvel
or follow pakistani-american teen hero
Kamala Khan in the comics Kamala isn't a
human who idolizes Carol Danvers and
takes up a pre Captain Marvel mantle
after discovering that she too has
superpowers showrunner Fisher K Ali
hasn't yet revealed whether the series
will show Kamala's first days as Miss
Marvel or whether it will pick up with
the character after she's already been
established similar to Peter Parker's
introduction in Captain America Civil
War Kamala plays new territory in the
comics as a first Muslim character to
headliner own Marvel book and to see her
on-screen in the MCU will be a
significant step forward in the battle
for more diverse representation in
Hollywood especially at the character
eventually crosses over to the film's we
don't have any idea yet when Miss Marvel
will hit Disney + or where it will fit
into Marvel's increasingly crowded
schedule however since the series was
announced as parts of Marvel's phase 4
timeline we can safely assume it'll be
before the end of 2021 the second of the
new Disney Plus shows announced at d23
2019 moonlight follows former mercenary
marc spector who gained superpowers from
the god khonshu during a mission that
goes sideways in egypt in many ways
moonlight has functioned in the comics
as Marvel's version of Batman sin
Spectre acts of the vigilante who uses
his substantial fortune to outfit
himself with advanced guided tree that
helps him hunt down bad guys
however Spectre comes with a unique
twist that's bound to make his
transition to screen both interesting
and potentially tricky in the comics
aspectus struggles with dissociative
identity disorder or di D which gives
him three distinct personalities in
addition to Spector there's also wealthy
businessman Steven Krantz and street
smart cab driver Jake luckily these
three personalities all work together to
help moonlight to battle evil and
munites creative team will have their
work cut out for them when it comes to
avoiding the problematic tropes are
often accompanied fictional portrayals
of characters worth di D moon night will
be helmed by Levite Sir Jeremy Slater
who previously developed the Umbrella
Academy comics into a successful series
for Netflix tweeting about his
involvement on Moon nights later wrote
we've assembled a room full of brilliant
writers who truly love this character
and we're all hard at work crafting
something special for you
the last of the Disney Plus shows
announced at d23 with she-hulk
which Wilson
around Bruce banners cousin Jennifer
waltzes in the comics Jennifer's an
attorney he receives the Hulk powers
from an emergency blood transfusion from
Bruce most likely Jennifer will gain her
powers sometime after the blip in a
Disney Plus series which will hopefully
mean we'll get at least a Mark Ruffalo
cameo in she-hulk if not a more
extensive role the she-hulk series will
be helmed by showrunner Jessica Gow who
won an Emmy for writing on the Rick and
Morty episode pickle wreck after who
will play Jennifer herself no casting
has been announced yet although fans
have proposed a variety of talented
actresses for the part including Jameela
Jamil Constance Wu Stephanie Beatrice
and Blake Lively thanks to motion
capture technology
whoever Marvel cast in the role will
probably not have to physically portray
Jennifer in a hotel state but will need
to embody her wits intelligence strong
moral compass and ability to snarkily
break the fourth wall as with MS marvel
the Moon Knight we don't know exactly
when she Hulk will slot into Marvel's
phase 4 schedule but expect it to be
before the end of 2021 check out one of
our newest videos right here plus even
more looper videos about the Marvel
Cinematic Universe are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and to
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you